one doctor who put it in my chart that i
said this happened after the vaccine but
he didn't say that he thought it but he
said it
verbally to me and so that was
interesting to me so one of the
immunologists he put it into his notes
you know i believe this is an
autoimmune thing but the the neurologist
just recorded what i had said
but verbally he said to me that he
believed this was caused by the vaccine
so i do think there is nervousness i do
think there is there is worriness in the
medical
uh community about
and and possibly in the research
community as well i'd be interested to
hear some anecdotes from uh
medical researchers who are a little
different from necessarily the doctors
with boots on the ground as to whether
they think that this is uh dangerous to
them if they were to publish studies of
that i don't know the answer to that
question yeah there's uh there's a
question about the formal danger to
people's careers and then there's a
lower level of coercion where people are
socially concerned of what happens if
they acknowledge a hazard and i will
point out
if you look at what's happening to eric
clapton
there is a very clear message
here we have a person i mean his
nickname is slow
right this is a person
who is famous for what he does with his
hands
he found himself unable to do what he
has done in life following a vaccination
again he can't be an anti-vaxxer he took
the vaccine willingly was injured and
let's say that he was the only person on
earth who had this or let's say that it
was a
pure coincidence and not causal somehow
still how
unkind is it to not allow a human being
to discuss his own experience and
experience that any of the rest of us in
his shoes would be saying the same thing
i feel like this vaccine caused this
problem with my
you know my hands the way that i my life
right ruined my life
and so i guess the point is i'm watching
him
uh
stigmatized publicly as if he is somehow
the culprit
right when at worst
he has drawn a connection that doesn't
deserve to be drawn and more likely
actually he's suffered an injury and
he's entitled to talk about it it just
seems to me so cruel
that society would take a position that
those who have had an experience must be
silent about it
um for fear that it will cause other
people to worry about something which
they should probably worry about
right exactly it should be possible to
say you you know you should be a little
more worried about that i'm perfectly
open to saying yeah i think people
should be more worried about this i
suggest today read an article uh from
australia i don't remember the name of
the person and i think it was yeah it
was a heart attack i think he had her no
maybe it was uh no maybe it was just
myocarditis anyway it was a heart
inflammation and uh
he was interviewed and they let him tell
a story and it went into the news but he
had to say over and over and over again
in the story i'm not trying to make
anybody vaccine hesitant i'm not it's
not my goal to make anyone hesitant
about getting the vaccine here in
australia and then he would go but at
the same time i do think this should be
studied more you know etc etc and and he
he was having trouble getting his thing
reported to the australian version of
theirs he had to do it himself but he
believed that if his doctor did it it
would have more um i don't know it would
be taken more seriously or whatever and
the doctor said i'm too busy you get
online and do it type thing and uh and
so even the the person writing the
articles seemed to accept that it had
been caused but kept saying rare rare
rare over and over again you know um but
it bothered me there was something very
propagandistic about the fact that this
man could only get his story told if he
said about five times i'm not trying to
make anybody vaccine hesitant well what
the heck he should be allowed to say man
i think maybe people should be more
hesitant about this and you still want
to tell a story it's an interesting
story
well i also i almost feel like this is
an epistemological crime i i don't know
if that's a category but i think the
point is a human being is not built for
a world of formal science a human being
is a brilliant creature that is capable
of taking information some of that
information will appear meaningful and
turn out not to be right but a human
being is
a human being needs to be able to say
look
my friend group
went and got vaccinated and there wasn't
an incident among them but you can't say
that if somebody who had had an incident
would have to think twice about speaking
publicly about it or they would have a
social catastrophe on their hands right
so the point is you don't know it seems
like the events are rare
but the
rarity may in par you know how many
people have been effectively silenced
watching what's happening to eric
clapton and saying you know what it's
not worth it i'm not simply not making
uh the connection
that is true as well um i watched an
interview with the lady her first name
is deborah she was a physician's
assistant you probably know the
interview i'm talking about anyway she
was um told by her fellow medical
practitioners you file the varus reports
we're too busy there are too many of
them etc even though they were
sufficiently important that they were
actually required by law to do it but
they let her do it for them for a while
and then they said no just do it on your
own patience um anyway
she
was um oh man i forgot where i'm going
going with this but oh i know what it
was she was saying that she had a
colleague an oncologist who took to
asking his patients
have you been vaccinated
so when their cancer was coming back out
of remission her colleague
was noticing the connection and the
patients were not
so i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you an
anecdote i'm gonna blind it a little bit
here because this person hasn't given me
permission but i was talking to someone
about my own experience and she said to
me and this was a medical person in the
medical field and she said to me oh it's
so interesting that you you had the
vaccine and you had this happen that's
odd i am
i had this thing where i was in terrible
pain and i was also i was out in the sun
and i almost anaful acted with a
temperature reaction and so forth and
then i woke up in the middle of the
night i was screaming in pain
and uh she said but i do think the
vaccine is safe
so she had made no connection whatsoever
until she heard my story and she's a
medical person
so i think it is under-reported and i
think one reason is what you're saying
people are afraid of social ostracism um
so we can't make that argument arguments
from silence kind of stink anyway but
but we can't make that argument from
silence i haven't heard anybody say
anything so it must not have happened in
my friend group that's very weak
argument but also because i think there
are cases where there is a plausible
connection but people are not making it
because they're as we say the prior
their prior is so low and so when their
prior is really low then they're not
they're not going to make that
connection
right
now
i of course haven't a clue what we are
supposed to
to do
with this right what ends up happening
is those of us who have
i guess accepted the price of
talking about our
negative experiences or our skepticism
our alarm our inability to look away
from the evidence that's accumulated in
the vares system or the yellow card
system
right we we have elected to pay a price
and so or
we have refused to dodge that price i
guess
and
we talk to each other and so that is
liable to be distorting in a sense right
when you find that you've got a group of
people who has already paid the price
and are
interacting and then you have another
group that isn't paying the price that
is surrounded by a great deal of silence
on the matter also not getting a clear
picture and of course
i think the problem is
i've said this in other contexts that
science is a very beautiful
and powerful process but it is also a
fragile process that it depends on
certain conditions being met and it is
not
capable it is not capable of overcoming
something like a propaganda campaign
that keeps evidence from emerging to a
place where we can evaluate it
and so
i don't you know i've been stigmatized
as all sorts of things including
uh an
anti-vaxxer and
i cannot seem to break through the wall
of people who need to be thinking about
why it is that people like you and i
would end up in this very
unpleasant situation of talking publicly
about something that powerful forces do
not want discussed now i know or just or
just blowing my own privacy like right
how many people want to go out there you
know i'm lucky right i my husband
supports me all right you know so i
don't think he's going to lose his job
because i came out and did this you know
so i'm not going to be penalized nearly
even as much as you have
but who wants to go out there and tell
people i have horrible tailbone pain you
know i mean it's usually something you
keep private it took me months to agree
to pay you know even that much of a
price but but you're right you know we
we don't want to be in in a bubble uh
and richard feynman the great physicist
said that science demands a particular
kind of honesty which is that you're
willing to bend over backwards to um
bring in things that might possibly be
contrary to to your own view you know
and he was funny he says i don't care if
you lie to your girlfriend but you when
you're a scientist you don't lie as a
scientist and and so that's that
fragility i think he in a sense sense
that fragility that you're talking about
there and i'm not sure what's going to
happen but i do
fear that signal is being broken as you
say and public trust is certainly eroded
and the proceeding of science at least
in things surrounding covid is being
broken in
the world as a whole i was going to say
the united states but other countries
too
yeah other countries too in fact uh
absolutely terrible stories coming out
of
australia i interviewed
a woman who has terrible immunological
sensitivities uh including anaphylactic
shock as a result of exposure uh to
polyethylene glycol which is in two of
the vaccines and a close relative is in
the third to which she has
access and she's being told she should
be vaccinated anyway she just should
simply get vaccinated in a hospital
where they can rescue her after she has
her anaphylaxis which
is a medically nonsensical position in
light of
the fact that this disease
as bad as it is is not
smallpox
it's uh also rare in australia so the
chances that anyone is actually
protected from covet itself by her being
vaccinated
makes no sense and
frankly many people who were reluctant
about vaccination and were vaccinated
anyway were vaccinated on the basis that
we needed to protect the vulnerable and
if she's not the vulnerable then who is
right right exactly and and now we're
hearing that myocarditis in children is
mild
so
we should be willing to send the
children out there vaccinate a bunch of
little kids and if they get myocarditis
hey it'll probably be mild never mind
the fact that covet would probably be
mild if they got coveted
so this is crazy covid would be mild as
far as we know myocarditis the idea that
this is a mild condition uh
is preposterous the idea that you would
imagine that it is likely to be mild in
children where they have a very long
life ahead of them in which
bad things can happen
right you would even take that risk
right there's no medical justification
at best the justification when it comes
to children is that it will protect the
old and infirm but we as a society have
never had the conversation where we say
it's acceptable to rob young people of
health to protect the old and infirm and
i think frankly only a sick society
would ever make such a choice ethically
horrible
right it's ethically indefensible in my
opinion and so yes we are not we're not
having that uh that conversation we're
also not
um
the other side is not planned fair
right heather and i were very clear
before there was evidence
of uh
myocarditis being
a frequent
i don't mean frequent in terms of the
number of people who have it but
frequent among the um the adverse events
we were alarmed that there was a danger
of hazards that we didn't know about yet
and that we should be cautious for that
reason and now of course how many people
have learned the term myocarditis
because it is well understood to be
caused by these vaccines where is the
acknowledgement that in fact our caution
was well placed right right right right
you know you predict things well and and
you can see that the
the propaganda machine is getting out
ahead of it so the very fact that we're
now being told myocarditis in children
is usually mild they can treat it with
you know advil at home or whatever what
is that it's it's
preliminary propaganda
it's it's a prophylactic propaganda you
might say so that if people say i told
you so here now we've got a bunch more
you know pericarditis and myocarditis
cases among children there wouldn't be
before they they're like yeah we already
knew that would happen we told you it
would be fine and not many very many of
them are dying so stop worrying about it
so basically nothing is going to be
allowed to to shake this it's a certain
view of what should be done and that
view is not going to change i i fear
yeah it's it's the ultimate
epistemological sin which is to start
with your conclusion and work backwards
from it and force the evidence to fit it
no matter what the evidence suggests
and
my husband likes to use the metaphor of
the pink panther if i recall correctly
and he's used this for years and that in
the introduction he would have a little
hole and he would go down the hole if
you've ever seen the cartoon and then he
would pull the hole
behind him
and then it would disappear
so he's
he's in there he's locked down in there
and that's what's happening we're doing
the pink panther yeah it's a kind of a
hermetically sealing a perspective so
that whatever evidence there is can't uh
can't alter it um that that is what
appears to be happening and there's just
simply nothing apparently that can
derail the strain which is the most
frightening thing of all
right if you had the sense that the
medical authorities
were grappling with the evidence and
that they were actually balancing the
question of the
harms of covid the deaths that will
arise from people getting sick with this
infection that we have not successfully
controlled and that they were balancing
that with the potential harm to people
from being vaccinated to prevent the
disease
well then there's a lot of discussion we
can have we under you know adults can
understand that this vaccine doesn't
have to be
uh completely safe in order to be
worthwhile but what one gets the sense
is that we've just sort of
definitionally decided it's safe and
that it has nothing to do with evidence
and that evidence you know will be
dismissed if it arises as it has
[Music]
you